[Music]
yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is the video for the short and
sweet cause on chasuble on the petrov
yeah in this video show you the main
lines of the petrov which is first of
all what is the petrov if you don't know
it this is the petrov defense
it's a black's main alternative within
the open games the double king pawns to
get going
96 where White has a huge choice of
theoretical main lines the Spanish
opening the Italian game the scotch and
so on instead we were looking we will be
looking at 90 f6 the Petrov defense
yeah the petrov is actually a quite
active opening we are not trying to
cover the e5 pawn White has detected but
rather trying to play a counter-attack
on the e4 pawn so we're not really
content with with yeah a passive
approach here white due to this threat
on the e4 pawn actually has a relatively
limited choice what to do this is a
pretty clean and straightforward
argument in favor of the petrov compared
to knight c6 because the yeah the range
of options it's just smaller and all all
things considered the petrov is less of
a theoretical work load to master than
96 this is some yeah definitely the case
one thing that I need to mention is in
the petrov if we look at just the start
of from an absolute main line you will
very often have the situation where both
a pawns are captured so we gave an open
e file here yeah the e-file is open and
this is very important to note the
petrov usually leads to open
positions there is no such thing as a
closed line in the petrol Frehley I mean
what can do something really really
inoffensive like d3 but well this is
rather obviously not a challenge for
black so we would have some trades shut
down painters trades in the centre in
pawn against a pawn it is a very likely
trade so the position opens up and it
will mostly be about peace play and very
classical values and shares peace play
and porn structures there is not much
maneuvering going on it's rather
something that is some concrete very
concrete move by move the open e file
however has an implication and this is
if we just go here again with an open
file already on there is always a higher
possibility of trades peace trades
it's just that often times pieces are
magically drawn to the open file and get
traded this is also why the petrov has
this reputation of being a rather boring
opening this is something that i want to
discuss a little bit right here at the
beginning because i don't think it is
entirely justified the petrov is a very
good start let's say four players four
if two if both players are completely
unofficial and just want to trade down
the board then they have the opportunity
to do so where the e-file is open you
can trader a trade but if both players
want to fight you will get it absolutely
no way around that
even from lines that looking at first
rather innocuous you will get
interesting positions the petrov to play
the petrov with black you just have to
avoid one scenario if you absolutely
with black need to win the game
nothing else is acceptable then you
should probably not play this opening
and somebody who is very competent at
theory and really knows how to
completely drain live life out of the
opening that is possible if wide
absolutely is an expert on Don chess in
general and knows the theory then they
might find ways to make it really really
boring
in this case it's not a great choice for
black but in your regular game against a
normal opponent this is just not
happening all that often so it wasn't
really very autumn or that much one
thing I need to mention is very
important the Petrov
[Music]